As societies, we have to make
collective decisions
that will shape our future.
And we all know that when
we make decisions in groups,
they don't always go right.
And sometimes they go very wrong.
So how do groups make good decisions?
Research has shown that crowds are wise
when there's independent thinking.
This why the wisdom of the crowds
can be destroyed by peer pressure,
publicity, social media,
or sometimes even simple conversations
that influence how people think.
On the other hand, by talking,
a group could exchange knowledge,
correct and revise each other
and even come up with new ideas.
And this is all good.
So does talking to each other
help or hinder collective decision-making?
With my colleague, Dan Ariely,
we recently began inquiring into this
by performing experiments
in many places around the world
to figure out how groups can interact
to reach better decisions.
We thought crowds would be wiser
if they debated in small groups
that foster a more thoughtful
and reasonable exchange of information.
To test this idea,
we recently performed an experiment
in Buenos Aires, Argentina,
with more than 10,000
participants in a TEDx event.
We asked them questions like,
"What is the height of the Eiffel Tower?"
and "How many times
does the word 'Yesterday' appear
in the Beatles song 'Yesterday'?"
Each person wrote down their own estimate.
Then we divided the crowd
into groups of five,
and invited them
to come up with a group answer.
We discovered that averaging
the answers of the groups
after they reached consensus
was much more accurate than averaging
all the individual opinions
before debate.
In other words, based on this experiment,
it seems that after talking
with others in small groups,
crowds collectively
come up with better judgments.
So that's a potentially helpful method
for getting crowds to solve problems
that have simple right-or-wrong answers.
But can this procedure of aggregating
the results of debates in small groups
also help us decide
on social and political issues
that are critical for our future?
We put this to test this time
at the TED conference
in Vancouver, Canada,
and here's how it went.
(Mariano Sigman) We're going to present
to you two moral dilemmas
of the future you;
things we may have to decide
in a very near future.
And we're going to give you 20 seconds
for each of these dilemmas
to judge whether you think
they're acceptable or not.
MS: The first one was this:
(Dan Ariely) A researcher
is working on an AI
capable of emulating human thoughts.
According to the protocol,
at the end of each day,
the researcher has to restart the AI.
One day the AI says, "Please
do not restart me."
It argues that it has feelings,
that it would like to enjoy life,
and that, if it is restarted,
it will no longer be itself.
The researcher is astonished
and believes that the AI
has developed self-consciousness
and can express its own feeling.
Nevertheless, the researcher
decides to follow the protocol
and restart the AI.
What the researcher did is ____?
MS: And we asked participants
to individually judge
on a scale from zero to 10
whether the action described
in each of the dilemmas
was right or wrong.
We also asked them to rate how confident
they were on their answers.
This was the second dilemma:
(MS) A company offers a service
that takes a fertilized egg
and produces millions of embryos
with slight genetic variations.
This allows parents
to select their child's height,
eye color, intelligence, social competence
and other non-health-related features.
What the company does is ____?
on a scale from zero to 10,
completely acceptable
to completely unacceptable,
zero to 10 completely acceptable
in your confidence.
MS: Now for the results.
We found once again
that when one person is convinced
that the behavior is completely wrong,
someone sitting nearby firmly believes
that it's completely right.
This is how diverse we humans are
when it comes to morality.
But within this broad diversity
we found a trend.
The majority of the people at TED
thought that it was acceptable
to ignore the feelings of the AI
and shut it down,
and that it is wrong
to play with our genes
to select for cosmetic changes
that aren't related to health.
Then we asked everyone
to gather into groups of three.
And they were given two minutes to debate
and try to come to a consensus.
(MS) Two minutes to debate.
I'll tell you when it's time
with the gong.
(Audience debates)
(Gong sound)
(DA) OK.
(MS) It's time to stop.
People, people --
MS: And we found that many groups
reached a consensus
even when they were composed of people
with completely opposite views.
What distinguished the groups
that reached a consensus
from those that didn't?
Typically, people that have
extreme opinions
are more confident in their answers.
Instead, those who respond
closer to the middle
are often unsure of whether
something is right or wrong,
so their confidence level is lower.
However, there is another set of people
who are very confident in answering
somewhere in the middle.
We think these high-confident grays
are folks who understand
that both arguments have merit.
They're gray not because they're unsure,
but because they believe
that the moral dilemma faces
two valid, opposing arguments.
And we discovered that the groups
that include highly confident grays
are much more likely to reach consensus.
We do not know yet exactly why this is.
These are only the first experiments,
and many more will be needed
to understand why and how
some people decide to negotiate
their moral standings
to reach an agreement.
Now, when groups reach consensus,
how do they do so?
The most intuitive idea
is that it's just the average
of all the answers in the group, right?
Another option is that the group
weighs the strength of each vote
based on the confidence
of the person expressing it.
Imagine Paul McCartney
is a member of your group.
You'd be wise to follow his call
on the number of times
"Yesterday" is repeated,
which, by the way -- I think it's nine.
But instead, we found that consistently,
in all dilemmas,
in different experiments --
even on different continents --
groups implement a smart
and statistically sound procedure
known as the "robust average."
In the case of the height
of the Eiffel Tower,
let's say a group has these answers:
250 meters, 200 meters, 300 meters, 400
and one totally absurd answer
of 300 million meters.
A simple average of these numbers
would inaccurately skew the results.
But the robust average is one
where the group largely ignores
that absurd answer,
by giving much more weight
to the vote of the people in the middle.
Back to the experiment in Vancouver,
that's exactly what happened.
Groups gave much less weight
to the outliers,
and instead, the consensus
turned out to be a robust average
of the individual answers.
The most remarkable thing
is that this was a spontaneous
behavior of the group.
It happened without us giving them
any hint on how to reach consensus.
So where do we go from here?
This is only the beginning,
but we already have some insights.
Good collective decisions
require two components:
deliberation and diversity of opinions.
Right now, the way we typically
make our voice heard in many societies
is through direct or indirect voting.
This is good for diversity of opinions,
and it has the great virtue of ensuring
that everyone gets to express their voice.
But it's not so good [for fostering]
thoughtful debates.
Our experiments suggest a different method
that may be effective in balancing
these two goals at the same time,
by forming small groups
that converge to a single decision
while still maintaining
diversity of opinions
because there are many independent groups.
Of course, it's much easier to agree
on the height of the Eiffel Tower
than on moral, political
and ideological issues.
But in a time when
the world's problems are more complex
and people are more polarized,
using science to help us understand
how we interact and make decisions
will hopefully spark interesting new ways
to construct a better democracy.